أعيد فتح البنوك اللبنانية للمرة الأولى
يوم الجمعة بعد إغلاقها لمدة
أسبوعين ، وكان هناك عدد أكبر من العملاء أكثر من
المعتاد ، لكن لم يكن هناك ذعر واضح.
القيود المفروضة على عمليات
السحب والتحويلات ، لم تكن
الجمعة السوداء هي التي خشي البعض من أن
الزعيم اللبناني لم ينخفض
ل كبير أمام الدولار ، لك
أساسيات الاقتصاد اللبناني ظل
متزعزعة للغاية ، فلديها ثا
ث أعلى نسبة دين إلى الناتج المحلي في العالم ، نص
عائدات الحكومة تذهب.  دف
الفوائد على القروض في البلاد
يعتمد بشكل كبير على الواردات تحدث
لأول مرة منذ
استقالة رئيس الوزراء سعود على الحريري قال
الأمين العام لحزب الله حسن
نصر الله أن الحكومة الجديدة
يجب أن تستعيد ثقة الناس من
خلال المساءلة والشفافية.
اتهم أنصار حزب الله
بمهاجمة المتظاهرين الآن
السياسيون المتشاجرون في لبنان يتحدثون  فيما
يتعلق بتشكيل حكومة جديدة ،
لا توجد فكرة واضحة ولكن متى يمكن
أن يحدث ذلك بالفعل بن ويدمان سي إن إن بيروت